[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 30
juin
la gestion des stocks de masques ne
revient pas au ministre face à la
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale alliès busin est toujours en
train de s'expliquer sur la gestion de
la crise elle qui avait démissionné de
son poste de ministre de la santé au
début de l'épidémie et de répondre au
député vous ne pouvez pas dire que nous
n'avons pas anticipé nouvelle journée
d'action nationale des personnels
soignants des dizaines de rassemblements
ont été organisés un peu partout en
france à quelques jours de la clôture du
ségur de la santé et les médecins
hospitaliers sont joints au cortège pas
convaincu non plus par les 300 millions
d'euros pour leurs salaires proposées
hier par le ministre de la santé le
royaume uni à la relance sous
l'impulsion de boris johnson et sous
influence du new deal américain le
premier ministre promet une révolution
par les infrastructures avec un plan de
5,5 milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie frappée par la bande des
pandémies à leicester au centre du
royaume uni c'est la douche froide pour
les habitants qui vont eux être à
nouveau
confiné
les chefs d'états du g5 celle emmanuel
macron à nouakchott en mauritanie
aujourd'hui objectif faire le point sur
les actions de lutte contre le
terrorisme dans la région
malgré un succès militaire français
certains l'instabilité sécuritaire dans
les états sahéliens menace toujours
autant les populations
[Musique]
comment la france at elle géré la crise
du coronavirus y at-il eu des fautes des
failles pourquoi a t'on manqué de
masques et de tests l'ancien ministre de
la santé répond toujours en ce moment
même aux questions de la commission d'
enquête sur cette gestion de la crise
sanitaire en france
une audition sous haute tension en cours
de laquelle agnès buzyn estime en tout
cas avoir alerté très tôt le président
de la république et le premier ministre
elle se défend d'avoir sous-estimé le
risque écouter l'ancien ministre de la
santé
mon premier peut-être nouveaux niveaux
d' alerte est je crois le autour du 11
janvier
parce que la chine annonce un premier
décès est donc on a d'une part
l'information que c'est un nouveau virus
de la famille du coronavirus et d'autre
part que ce virus peut être grave
puisque un décès rapportés et donc je
décide à ce moment-là de la forme et le
président de la république et le premier
ministre qu'il existe un phénomène en
chine tout cela est suivi par le chorus
qui se met au niveau de veille de niveau
2 autour du 22 janvier pour une raison
c'est à dire que vous me demander ma
prise de conscience est en réalité la
prise de conscience évolue parce que le
22 janvier l'om est-ce dit qu'il y à une
transmission interhumaine
et c'est là où l'on comprend que ce
n'est pas un phénomène local qui est
liée au marché aux poissons ou un
réservoir animal mais qu'à partir du
moment où il ya une transmission
interhumaine avéré à ce moment là il
peut y avoir un phénomène épidémique et
pour en parler nous sommes avec fabrice
di vizio avocat du collectif c 19
bonsoir
dieu merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on le rappelle un avocat
d'un collectif de plus de 600 médecins
ayant porté plainte précisément contre
agnès buzyn edouard philippe pour leur
gestion de la crise du coroner virus on
imagine que vous attendiez avec
impatience cette audition est ce que
vous en sortez avec des débuts de
réponses ou des réponses tout court
alors oui et non c'est à dire que j'ai
quand même appris quelque chose qui est
important j'ai appris que le ministre de
la santé dans ce pays ne gouverne pas
j'ai appris que nous avions eus
d'administration totalement autonome qui
fait ce qu'elle veut quand elle veut
quand elle veut sans que le ministre ne
soit même informé on demande à madame
buzyn mais enfin les stocks de masques
quand saviez vous on a alerté le dgs je
ne fais rien le ministre ne sait rien
mais enfin elle dit à abandonner mais
des ministres ne sait pas que je
découvre au mois de janvier
finalement que la production mondiale se
fait en chine
je l'ignorais avant c'est
l'administration qui le savaient et à
plusieurs reprises madame boutin va dire
moi je ne savais pas c'est
l'administration qui savait sauf que
madame d'user oublie quelque chose ces
articles 20 de la constitution qui fait
que le gouvernement ait bien dirige
l'administration
l'administration est placé sous la
responsabilité du gouvernement et donc
si ce qu'elle dit est vrai c'est
particulièrement inquiétant parce que
donc ça veut dire qu'il peut se passer
n'importe quoi et que le ministre n'ait
pas informé on a une administration qui
est totalement autonome
elle a fait brésil je vous propose de
préciser le monde écoute et agnès buzyn
sur cette question majeure évidemment
des masques écoutez sa réponse je
voudrais vous dire la commande de 2 1
millions de du 30 janvier en fait en
fait moi je comme je demande qu'on
recommande des masques ce week end là le
temps que la commande de parts elle par
le trompe
aurait été de quel masque parlons nous à
ce moment là nous parlons de masques
ffp2 en fait je prends la décision le 28
janvier alors qu'il n'y a pas d' urgence
de santé publique internationale de
portée internationale pardon ms je
prends la décision de constituer un
stock d'état de masques ffp2 parce qu'il
n'y en a pas vous savez que c'est la
doctrine de 2 min il n'y a pas de stock
d'état pour les masques ffp2 et je me
dis peut-être je me dis qu'il va falloir
des masques parce que je me projette
toujours dans une infection de rome et
la doctrine de 2011 qui remet la
responsabilité des masques ffp2 aux
employeurs aux hôpitaux aux indépendants
parce qu'en réalité dans la doctrine de
2011 c'est aux professionnels de santé
de s'équiper eux mêmes
je me dis mieux vaut commander des
masses sans savoir quels sont les
besoins de terrain puisque les ars ne
m'ont pas encore répondu je leur ai
demandé je fais partir le 28 janvier une
demande aux adresses de me faire
remonter les besoins de terrain des
établissements et des professionnels ils
demandaient rien et je me dis en
attendant cette réponse commandant des
masques et faisons un stock des tags
n'existe pas alors fabrice di vizio vous
entendez la réponse d'agnès busan un
coût qui se protège quand même qui se
défend en tout cas elle a pris les
bonnes décisions
selon elle qu est-ce que vous inspire
cette réponse un c'est faux la gauthrin
de 2011 ne vient pas à mettre à la
charge des indépendants et des libéraux
la constitution de masques ça c'est fou
elle le met la charge des employeurs à
partir de 2013 n'est pas les libéraux ça
c'est le premier point mais il ya un
deuxième point qui interpelle quand même
si je comprends bien ce que dit madame
buse
moi j'ai aucune raison penser que c'est
grave je pense et aucune raison mais
quand même comme je suis quelqu'un de
vachement bien
bah je vais commander un million de
basse bon d'accord il en faut un
milliard mais j'en commande un million
pourquoi premier élément deuxième
élément elle doit demander aux ars fait
sa cohérence discours elle demande aux
ars de lui faire remonter les besoins
des hôpitaux mais si halloween
on se mettait à la charge des hôpitaux
le soir de commander des masques
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait remonter quoi
que ce soit au ministère et nous
touchons au coeur du problème
cette commission denquête n'aboutira à
rien je le répète depuis le premier jour
madame du zoo donnez moi mais c'est
important en gros la ministre nous dit
ben les commandes c'est nous mais la
gestion des stocks c'est pas nous c'est
celle agences de santé est-ce que c'est
recevable pour l'avocat vous êtes ça ça
je veux dire ça sur ce coup là c'est
totalement fou si pas comme ça que ça se
passera pendant un débat doctrinal et le
gr20 juge mais c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe
et concrètement nous sommes au coeur du
problème c'est à dire que madame du sein
est chez elle
personne n'est là pour lui apporter la
contradiction parce qu'on aurait pu lui
demander mais enfin madame je comprends
pas vous me dites que vous sonnez
l'alertent des mois de décembre mais
pourquoi si vous sautez l'alertent vous
attendez la fin du mois de janvier pour
commander des masques enfin deuxième
élément pourquoi vous informer le
président de quelque chose qui est
totalement anecdotique
vous informez souvent président de ce
qu' il ya une grippe en chine
c'est totalement pourquoi oui mais parce
que je mesurais la gravité déjà
potentiellement mais alors vous mesurer
la gravité mais vous faites rien son
discours est plein de contradictions que
personne n'a relevé comment voulez-vous
mais parce qu'elle est chez elle madame
busin d'ailleurs un détail vous allez
remarquer elle est au même rang que
rapporteur et le président elle est pas
en face d'eux elle est exactement sur la
même table tout est dit à partir de là
symboliquement je trouve que ça vole et
extraordinaire elle est au même rang en
tout cas le défend l'action du
gouvernement dans son enfant nous avons
anticipé par rapport aux alertes
internationale ce qu'on a mis en place
dès le 10 janvier 10 janvier et sans
aucune commune mesure avec les autres
pays
mais comment peut-elle dire ça comment s
il ya bien falloir qu'on arrête un
moment donné gir de mentir effrontément
de cette fois quand même on est à côté
d'un pays l'allemagne qui a géré ça de
manière absolument presque parfaite
nous avons l'autriche nous avons la
pologne je peux en citer devint comme ça
la plupart des journées feront quelque
la star de mu brousse qui en gros nous
pardonnez-moi familièrement qui nous a
mis dedans voilà ce qu'elle a répondu
pour la question de la
leur dis madame busin a toujours une
réponse à tous de toute façon madame
buzyn si vous voulez lui dit quelque
chose moi l'allemagne je sais pas elle
dit je sais pas je suis pas
épidémiologie je suis pas infectiologues
mais voici une explication madame
bullens toujours le même problème
elle ne sait rien et elle dit tout notre
les moments où elle sait tout mais ne
dit rien là elle ne sait rien mais elle
dit tout je veux dire il arrive un
moment donné où la vérité de cette
histoire est relativement simple
nous sommes à plus de 30000 morts et on
vient vous expliquer depuis le début de
cette commission denquête que c'est
faute à pas de chance que nous avons été
parfaits nous avons géré ce système de
ce set by me avec un système parfait qui
a tout anticipé mais on est à trente
mille morts quand même c'est quand même
fou le rôle d'une petite voix la
parenthèse sur l'om est selon ms pensé
que ce n'était pas une urgence m'ont dit
agnès buzyn j'ai même appelé son
président pour savoir pourquoi
clairement le rôle de l' oms est à
questionner quand on l'entend ce type de
choses je trouve que c'est
extraordinaire de questionner le rôle de
dms quand ça nous arrange et finalement
de ne plus le questionner quand ça nous
arrange pas l'om est ce effectivement
dès le 30 janvier vous disent qu'il faut
faire quand il déclare l'urgence
sanitaire international il vous explique
l'importance notamment du dépistage et
des tests est-ce qu effectivement on l'a
fait au mois de mars
il vous explique test test test et vous
avez jérôme salomon qui est venu dans
l'oeuvre dans cette même commission
vous expliquez que ça ne concernait pas
je veux dire il arrive à un moment donné
où on appelle l oms en garant de
moralité quand ça nous arrange et on
l'enfoncé quand ça nous arrange on
s'interroge aussi mais vous toucher au
coeur du problème
cette commission denquête n'a aucun
pouvoir de coercition
elle n'a pas de pouvoir des
perquisitions elle n'a pas le pouvoir de
demander des pièces en tout cas d exiger
et c'est madame busin déclare ce qu'elle
veut jérôme ça le monde déclare ce qu'il
veut il n'y aura pas de vérité qui
sortira de cette commission denquête je
m'évertue à le répéter depuis le premier
jour j'avais davantage confiance à la
justice puisqu'on rappelle vos dépôts de
plaintes est ce que vous en attendez
plus tard mais vous savez pour une
raison très simple c'est que j'ai déposé
plainte aujourd'hui devant le doyen des
juges d'instruction de paris contre
l'administration à constitution de
partie civile
eh bien je vais pouvoir contrôler ce qui
se passe et la saisine du juge
d'instruction
elle a un effet c'est qu'elle met fin à
cette mascarade de commission denquête
puisque ne peuvent pas coexister une
information judiciaire et une enquête
parlementaire et surtout dernier point
j'aurai accès au dossier
nous aurons des pièces et alors nous
pourrons commencer à discuter
et ce ne sera plus les déclarations des
uns ou des autres sous un serment à la
valeur très relative
mais ce sera la charge de la preuve
merci beaucoup à fabrice di vizio avant
cadre du collectif c 19 d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france voulait
se reprendre
l'audition daniel cousin qui se
poursuivront la commission de
l'assemblée nationale est en tout cas on
subit de plein fouet la crise du corps
d'un virus les personnels hospitaliers
étaient à nouveau dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour réclamer
avantage de moyens pour l'hôpital les
dizaines de rassemblements ont eu lieu
en france à paris le cortège s'est
élancé en début d'après midi de l'ancien
hôpital militaire du val-de-grâce
direction le ministère de la santé
les manifestations autorisées par la
préfecture de police et manifestations
en tous cas qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme les précisions de notre reporter
sur place katia technique des milliers
de personnes ont défilé à paris
aujourd'hui pour cette journée de
mobilisation des soignants à paris le
rassemblement était organisé par les
syndicats fo sud la cgt unsa également
lé collectif inter urgence et inter
hôpitaux la raison de leur colère
aujourd'hui est bien pour eux le ségur
ne tient pas ses promesses à il s'agit
comme vous le savez d'un blanc massif de
revalorisation et d'investissement
souhaité par le président français
l'opération qui a démarré le 25 mai va
s'achever le vendredi ce vendredi mais
pour le moment le compte n'y est pas
selon les syndicats alors une enveloppe
de 6 milliards a bien été débloqués par
le ministre de la santé olive et veyran
mais cela ne conviendrait pas les
syndicalistes nous en parle par exemple
il verrier le secrétaire général de
force ouvrière
on reprend avec les politiques d'avant
or j'avais cru comprendre que l'après ne
serait pas comme avant et en particulier
en matière de santé le président de la
république lui même a dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas considérer la santé comme
une seule variable financière et bien il
faut qu'on cesse avec ses politiques et
si on reprend les politiques d'avant bah
ça n'ira pas ça c'est clair donc il faut
qu'on revienne là-dessus
même incrédulité chez le personnel
soignant que nous avons rencontrés
aujourd'hui une infirmière et d'un
formateur en soins infirmiers nous
évoque ces premières annonces qui selon
elles ne répondent pas aux besoins de la
profession et aux revendications qu'elle
porte depuis des mois c'est insuffisant
le gouvernement là il a un problème
c'est qu'il ya eu une grande solidarité
de la population pour soutenir tous les
hospitaliers et sans souci c'est qu'il
essaye par tous les moyens d'arrêter
cette mobilisation
on sait très bien que les revendications
première c'était l'augmentation des
salaires des grilles salariales pour
l'ensemble des hospitaliers quand je
parle des hospitaliers ce sont les
soignants mais également tous les autres
métiers qui font de l'hôpital public
l'hôpital public des soignants excédé
d'avoir été appelé héros et qui se
sentent aujourd'hui abandonnés
le cortège s'est arrêté devant le
ministère de la santé et s'est dispersée
dans le calme vers 17 heures il portait
aujourd'hui toutes les revendications un
killer qu'il tente d'affirmer depuis des
mois donc c'est à dire plus de
recrutement l'arrêt des fermetures de
lits l'arrêt des restructurations
évidemment des augmentations de salaires
plus de formation voici le sens de cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui qu'ils
entendaient peser sur les ultimes
négociations du ségur ray les syndicats
et collectifs hospitalier entend donc on
l'aura compris maintenir la pression sur
l'exécutif dans la dernière ligne droite
du ségur de la santé pour en parler nous
sommes avec nathalie cucine economy
spécialiste de la santé bonsoir nathalie
comptines et merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés pour cette partie décryptage
stéphanie oui y est infirmière bloc
opératoire chu de béziers secrétaire
général du collectif inter bloc bonsoir
à vous aussi merci d'être avec nous
alors déjà petite question voilà qui
vous concerne et aussi avant d'évoquer
ce ségur de la santé cette journée de
mobilisation on imagine que vous avez
écouté en tout cas d'une oreille
l'audition d'agnès busin avec la
question des masques qui vous a beaucoup
touché 1 stéphanie juillet dans les
hôpitaux donc en clair la ministre
n'était pas responsable de cette gestion
des stocks de masques elle était
uniquement responsable des commandes
l'état fait tout son possible et
n'aurait pas pu mieux gérer
en tout cas en termes d'anticipation
vous avez été convaincu par votre ex
ministre de la santé
non tu mens pas c'est l'effet sur une
heure on a bien vu sur le terrain nous
qu'on n'avait pas de masques notamment
des masques ffp2 qui sont les seuls je
tiens à le préciser à protéger contre le
coc vie même si certaines
recommandations parlent simplement des
masques chirurgicaux faut savoir que
nous au bloc par rapport à la grosse
mobilisation du virus on est en première
ligne
donc forcément le ffp2 et le seul qui
nous protège et le sp2 est celui qui
manque cruellement et même encore à ce
jour dans tous les blocs nous ça a été
comme partout en france d'ailleurs ça a
été la solidarité nationale et citoyenne
qui a fait que nous avons eu des masques
ffp2 bien souvent ils étaient périmés
mais bon c'était mal pour un bien on va
dire on s'est protégé avec ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a eu à disposition
nathalie continer sont commentées dans
les détails votre impression sur
l'audition d'agnès buzyn c'est ça a
l'air d'être un petit peu quand même des
réponses toutes faites bon sont les
masques elle devait pas des commandes et
par devait commander mais c'est pas elle
qui est à l'origine de la commande par
mois je pense que de cette commission
denquête ne sortira pas grand chose
effectivement et que franchement le
gouvernement en tout cas au début de la
crise ne s'est un peu pris les pieds
dans le tapis c'est moins compliqué
alors on va pas c'est donc à cette
mobilisation
à quelques jours de la fin du ségur de
la santé stéphanie juillet vous êtes
satisfait de cette journée de
mobilisation ça fait des mois des mois
et des mois que vous vous rassemblez il
ya eu les dernières annonces du ministre
qui datent d'ailleurs d'hier
vous espérez encore que ça puisse porter
ses fruits
on espère on espère toujours de toute
façon s'ils sont mobilisables et un
historien le rapport de forces qu'on
arrivera sans doute à quelque chose mais
non on n'est pas satisfait de tes
réponses qu'on nous apporte jusqu'à
maintenant puisqu'on ne parle d'une
enveloppe de 6 milliards d'euros pour
les personnels non médicaux donc les
infirmiers les as les manips radio 6
milliard d'euros et fait savoir que ça
répond pas du tout à la l'augmentation
que l'on espère qu'ils celui de 300
euros net par mois par agent ça ne même
sept français en euros ne rattrape pas
encore la place désastreuse chorena de
la moyenne nationale de toute la moyenne
européenne des salaires des infirmiers
donc sinon on n'est pas satisfait bien
sûr que non après au niveau mobilisation
nous on voit bien que la mobilisation
est forte que les soignants sont excédés
écoeuré enragé donc je pense que de
toute façon on lâchera rien
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible on
ne peut pas avoir fait tout ça pour
arrêter maintenant donc on va continuer
soixante session nathalie continue
pourtant ce qu'on se trompe rang tandis
que ces 6 milliards d'euros c'est sans
aucune commune mesure avec ce qui a pu
être mis sur la table lors des
précédents plan en faveur du secteur
certes mais ce donc il faut bien mon
avis rendre compte c'est que ça fait
plus d'un an que les soignants on est le
collectif à quelles urgences collectif
inter hôpitaux donc ça fait plus d'un an
que les soignants sont mobilisés partout
en france pour défendre l'hôpital public
la réponse du gouvernement pour le
moment n'a absolument pas été à la
hauteur des attentes et des besoins de
cet hôpital public même si ce
gouvernement n'est pas responsable de
l'état de délabrement pendant lequel
progressivement les différents
gouvernements
l'hôpital public il est face à une crise
qui a montré à l'ensemble de la
population que les revendications de ces
personnels étaient pour le moins
légitime
on a tous vu des photos de deux
soignants avec des blues fait ça couvait
ou des masques donner généreusement par
la population autour donc l'hôpital
public et sous et sous-équipés sous
financé ces personnels sont mal payés il
ya des femmes d'organisation qui sont
importants
la dimension administrative est beaucoup
trop fort qu'il faut revoir la
gouvernance il faut revoir
l'organisation du système de soins dans
son ensemble lien avec les personnes
nées les médecins libéraux pour la
permanence des soins à l'avenir avec les
cliniques privées
donc il ya beaucoup de difficultés
autour de cet hôpital public et pour le
moment la réponse des gouvernements est
très très en dessous des besoins de
l'hôpital public et bien sûr des
attentes des soignants qui vivent ça
tous les jours au fond quotidien alors
quotidiennement les soignantes pour
confrontée à ces difficultés alors
stéphanie mais une question aussi de
répartition en séminaire c'est beaucoup
d'argent on l'a dit mais on apprend
aussi que cette enveloppe va aller vers
les ehpad et cliniques privées ce qui
n'était pas nécessairement prévu dans
les négociations disons que il faut bien
que ça soit à partager avec tout le
monde puisque c'est tous les soignants
en globalité kidman une augmentation est
pas peu les hôpitaux il ya aussi
effectivement les ehpad ya les cliniques
privées
on est tous logés à la même enseigne le
souci qui est assez commun cette
enveloppe va encore être redistribuées
est-ce qu'elle va être redistribué à la
mode prime qu'ovide comme ça a été le
cas certaines 507 certains 1500 d'autres
milliers d'autres aurier c'est tout ça
qui est inquiétant c'est qu'on se doute
bien que ça va pas du tout satisfaire ce
que ce que l'on attend et ça va
certainement pas sauver le peu de
service public qui nous reste et moi
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'inquiétude par
rapport à la suite de
la gestion de cette crise parce que la
crise est passé pour le moment on sait
très bien que dans certaines régions il
ya des cas de convives de nouveaux qui
reviennent en force
si on doit subir une deuxième vague et
ben je ne sais pas comment on va la
gérer
et puis c'est pas un redistribuable
comme ils comptent le faire ou on verra
demain ce que valent ces messieurs bien
mais je crains beaucoup encore que ce
soit a fait un peu de manière arbitraire
et c'est tout à fait humain une âme ici
alors nathalie continue autres courroux
de la part des personnels médicaux cette
fois une enveloppe de 300 millions
d'euros à destination des quelque cent
mille 1 personnels médicaux ça a été
annoncé hier par le ministre c'est très
insuffisant on imagine pour ses médecins
bien sûr mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que ces histoires de
salaire ou ce soit les soignants ou les
personnels médicaux aux tous les
personnels qui sont autour de l'hôpital
c'est pas seulement une juste
rémunération pour pour ses personnels
bien sûr que son nom est oui mais c'est
au delà de ça sûr que les rémunérations
sont tellement faibles dans l'hôpital
public comparé soit à la difficulté vis
en région parisienne par exemple sous
aux salaires comparés au privé par
exemple que les hôpitaux publics
n'arrivent plus à recruter dans
l'hôpital public notamment en
ile-de-france ya des centaines et des
centaines de postes qui sont disponibles
mais qui ne sont pas pourvus donc
annoncé des créations de poste n'a pas
de sens si ses créations de postes ne ne
trouve pas preneur
donc la question des rémunérations elle
est double elle est à la fois pour les
personnels que ce soit les médecins ou
les soignants la bleue prêts à pratiquer
même parce que ça c'est une rémunération
qu'il mérite en tout cas pour les
soignants et ils en ont besoin et ça a
été rappelé des salaires aujourd'hui des
infirmiers sont très bas dans l'échelle
de des rémunérations européenne des deux
personnes à l'équivalent donc ça c'est
pas normal mais c'est aussi parce que si
ces salaires ne sont pas revalorisés on
ne trouvera pas de personnel dans les
hôpitaux publics et qu'effectivement là
on peut s'inquiéter très fortement de
que ceux qui de ce qui va se passer pour
ces hôpitaux publics
alors comme ça a été dit s'il ya une
deuxième vague mais tout ça
le mans si on a besoin nous l'ensemble
de la population d'aller se faire
soigner parce que sans personnel c'est
son délit et qui ferment ce sont aussi
des malades qui n'ont pas accompagné
donc on n'a pas le temps de s'occuper de
ayons c'est que il ya des soins
proprement dits mais y'a plein de choses
autour du soin qui sont nécessaires pour
que ces patients puissent puis se guérir
et supporter leur séjour à l'hôpital
donc c'est la survie aussi de l'hôpital
public qui est en jeu de danse et
questions financières et de salaire et
on attendra donc les annonces d'olivier
verrons demain merci à toutes et de
nathalie comptines et stéphanie juillet
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france après cette nouvelle journée de
mobilisation des soignants dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
à du plan rooseveltiens dévoilé ce mardi
par morrison afin de relancer l'économie
britannique
et puis direction la mauritanie où s'est
tenu le sommet des chefs d'état du g5
celle en présence d'emmanuel d'un cran
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qui est un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse est fort dans
mondial on essaie de le faire perdurer
mais on est à la fin d'un modèle qui
était le tout misé sur la dette la dette
et la relance par la dette ou par la
création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est en imprimant des billets
que vous relancer une économie si on
essaie autant de relancer la croissance
économique s'est peu fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire ce en passant
c'est connu on ne peut pas continuer à
diffuser des chiffres qui sont
absolument faux simplement parce que ça
arrange monsieur trump à ce moment là
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente vers une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
sa cuisine je me suis aperçu que c'était
bien plus difficile qu'ils avaient une
équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour nous
pour nos fournisseurs pour nos équipes
c'était essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt
possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le comte d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver
on sait que ça allait me rendre plus
tolérante et ben ça m'a rendu plus
intolérant alors parfois elle s'était
d'ailleurs ne devrait vous proposer
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le montana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure de paris merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france au
royaume-uni boris johnson a donc
présenté son plan de relance économique
suite à la crise du kobe 19 le premier
ministre britannique promet le site une
révolution par les infrastructures avec
un plan de l'ordre de 5 milliards et
demi d'euros
il a refusé tout retour à une politique
d'austérité
par ailleurs plus de 15 milliards
d'euros vont être alloués à l'éducation
l'ancien maire de londres a également
réaffirmé sa promesse de campagne
construire 40 hôpitaux à 12h30 que
l'économie la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons ça batna parce que comme je les
dis nous gérons l'économie avec prudence
c'est que c'est le bon moment pour
emprunter ce que nous disons c'est que
c'est le bon moment de faire cet effort
durable et massif pour faire que le
royaume uni surmonter cette épreuve
parce que cela nous permettra de
durablement gagner en productivité ce
qui à la fin nous permettra d'augmenter
les recettes fiscales qui resteront
indispensables nous pourrons équilibré
tout ça avec le temps mais ils devront
absolument investir maintenant et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
leicester au royaume uni avec alister
jones professeur associé de politique à
l'université de montfort de leicester
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir mr jones merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on l'a entendu
le plan inspiré du new deal et pas de
retour à l'austérité pour boris johnson
c'est une bonne stratégie selon vous
c'est un bilan extrêmement beau ce qu'il
a promis aujourd'hui avait déjà été
premier auparavant il parle de hauteur à
dépenses de 5 milliards de livres afin
de revitaliser l'économie et sortir du
désastre causé par la pandémie de gros
navires us étudie les détails cela
devient un peu troublant donc un il y a
pour les écoles très bien sauf que il y
a dix ans il y avait déjà un milliard
pour les écoles une stratégie de série t
il titulaire a pas de retard à
l'austérité c'est une bonne chose mais
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan 5
milliards de livres ce n'est pas du tout
assez ce n'est pas du tout suffisant
pour relancer l'économie
dans notre programme de chômage partiel
ont un goût vrai au niveau du
gouvernement
80% halte et les salaires et cela
coûtait déjà beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
et donc tout ça c'est des centimes eux
qu'on trouve sous le canapé alors tout
même dans l'essonne que mise clairement
il le dit sur l'emprunt et donc sur la
dette un pays évidemment qui est déjà
très endetté ce sont les générations
futures qui paieront ça pose de problème
à personne
oui c'est un problème les sur la
perspective longue
l'idée est qu'une grosse partie de la
dette pourrait être remboursé rapidement
mais c'est faux cette aide sera
remboursé
sur les cinquante prochaines années si
l'on regarde par exemple la seconde
guerre mondiale les dettes non c'était
complètement remboursé gueule environ
cinquante ans après la fin de la guerre
c'est un problème mais le taux d'intérêt
est très bas et nous avons déjà des
plans en place pour le rembourser donc
le gouvernement tant sa la perspective
de longues
ici on adopter des mesures d'austérité
cette économie s'effondrer davantage la
récession serait plus forte donc c'est
un investissement à long terme de la
part du gouvernement pour le peuple
effectivement il faudra le rembourser
mais les taux d'intérêt sont bas et la
position fiscale devrait être assez
sousse dit au royaume uni pour que cela
ne pose pas vraiment de gros problèmes
est-ce que clairement c'est la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne qui
permet aujourd'hui à boris johnson cette
marge de manoeuvre est de mise et
justement sur la dette et éviter
l'austérité veut pas que le thé par
l'union européenne puisse être liée à ce
point avec la réaction du clan
coronavirus effectivement tout temps
l'union européenne nous avons plus de
flexibilité européenne de toute façon va
lancer des programmes de financement
supplémentaire si l'union européenne ne
le fait pas alors elle même va se
retrouver dans de beaux draps
donc nous avons un peu plus de
flexibilité aux rails mais bien sûr ce
n'est en vérité il faut s'attendre à ce
que tous les membres importants de
l'union européenne fasse la même chose
alors à l'histoire jones vous êtes en
direct également on l'a dit de leicester
on imagine que pour vous c'est la douche
froide un surplace puisque vous allez
devoir subir 1re confinement quel est
l'état d'esprit des habitants comment
vous le vivez les états d'esprit sont
divers beaucoup de personnes
sont très en colère parce qu'elle
attendait avec impatience le 4 juillet
lorsque les agents vont nous
britanniques vont réouvrir un retour à
la normalité
il ya également beaucoup de frustration
car le gouvernement central a attendu
très longtemps avant de réinstaurer le
confinant à une easter le ministre de la
santé a déclaré il ya quelques jours il
y à une épidémie
alister sans rien faire alors que ça
fait longtemps que l'on sait que c'est
le cas certes il y a eu du jeu l'onu
nouveaux tests supplémentaires mais on
aurait dû réagir beaucoup plus vite à
leur caf on aurait dû être il ya deux
semaines et nous aurions peut-être pu
être en train d'en sortir aujourd'hui
dans une situation plus stable
donc il ya beaucoup de frustration à
cause de la lenteur du gouvernement à
réagir et c'est très frustrant le maire
de la ville est très en colère car il
bénéficie de très peu d'informations il
y à onze jours de cela nous avons
assisté à cette émission du gouvernement
disant qu'il y avait une épidémie a dans
la vie et c'est ce jour là qu'il a
appris et la réalité
donc il ya des informations qui ne passe
pas au niveau local et cela est vrai
dans tout le pays
au royaume uni les gens sont très en
colère car le pouvoir central garde des
informations et ne formons pas les
gouvernements locaux sur la situation
dans la région
dernière petite question leicester
affiche entre cinq et dix fois plus de
cas positifs à un kobe 19 que dans le
reste du pays d'où seront confinement
est ce que vous arrivez à vous expliquer
pourquoi
va à une ombre avril soit il ya
plusieurs facteurs la rotule relâchement
du conflit on est parce que les gens ont
recommencé à sortir la veille de
confinement était trop rapide et
beaucoup de personnes ne respectait pas
les règles ne pas se rassembler à plus
de cent personnes les personnes ne
seraient que ça et ce n'était pas vrai
call leicester mais dans tout le pays
nous avons des images de plages
complètement couverte de gens qui
oublient totalement les règles de plus
dans l'autre ville nous avons beaucoup
de logements très proches les uns des
autres bien plus que dans d'autres
régions britanniques avons certaines
communautés où plusieurs générations
verte ans en mai puis deux trois voire
quatre générations qui vivent dans le
même logement dans des logements parfois
exécute et cela a admis une
contamination plus simple de plus il n'y
a pas eu assez de test et c'est vrai à
leicester mais également dans le reste
du pays des personnes contaminées
pouvait se déplacer et continue à
contaminer d'autres personnes sans
savoir qu'ils étaient porteurs et c'est
vrai dans tout le pays c'est vraiment un
gros problème notre stratégie de test
est déplorable
merci beaucoup à leicester jones d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
emmanuel macron à nouakchott en
mauritanie aujourd'hui pour participer
au sommet du g5 celle un avis retour sur
la journée pour le chef de l'état
français le temps de s'entretenir avec
ses homologues pour faire le point sur
la lutte anti jihadistes pour rappel
plus de cinq mille soldats français sont
déployés au sahel sera donc question de
l'opération barkan six mois après le
sommet de pau il avait été décidé de
l'intensification de l'effort commun
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme et la
roque conquête du terrain perdu dans la
région à son atterrissage emmanuel
macron s'est félicité des succès de
cette coopération
nous avons durant ces six derniers mois
connus de vrais succès dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme avec la
neutralisation de chef redouté et qui
ont été sanglants pour toute la région
et qui ont fait beaucoup de mal aux
populations civiles parce que nous avons
réussi à améliorer notre organisation en
matière de sécurité de partage de
l'information parce qu'il ya une vraie
montée en gamme de l'intervention des
armées sahélienne devons faire davantage
en matière de retour de l'état et dans
beaucoup de régions il est important que
la consolidation de l'état soit
maintenue je pense en particulier à ce
qui doit être fait au mali au burkina
dans un contexte on le sait très
compliqué et pour en parler nous sommes
avec mériadec raffray secrétaire général
de l'association des journalistes de
défense bonsoir mais après merci d'être
avec nous cette réunion doit donc
permettre de faire le point et de savoir
ses engagements pris à pour ont été
tenus
est-ce que ça a été le cas selon vous
bonsoir stéphanie écouter au il ya je
pense qu'il faut distinguer deux choses
le volet militaire d'une part je pense
qu'effectivement les en six mois en fait
la france et ses partenaires africains
ont marqué un certain nombre de deux
points ils ont avancé un opérationnel à
l'état major des armées disaient il ya
quelques jours les choix faits ce sont
manifestes sont manifestement les bons à
propos des choix tactiques et
stratégiques militaires qui ont été
faits en janvier au sommet de pau je
voulais rappelle peut-être on a on a
décidé d'augmenter la participation le
nombre de militaires françaises sur le
terrain on est passé de quatre mille
cinq cents environ à un peu plus de 5000
ce qui a permis évidemment de 2 comment
dirais-je de desserrer un peu la tension
qui qui reposaient sur les épaules de
barkan qui je vous le rappelle le
travail dans un espace de plus de 4000
km de long sur plus de 1500 de large
on a décidé également d'un point de vue
militaire de nomadiser encore plus de
vraiment nos valises est en quelque
sorte
pendant ces six mois écoulés en
particulier durant la période de
sécheresse intense
les militaires français ont organisé
pendant plus de trois semaines sur le
terrain dans les conditions donc je le
rappelais difficile que peu d'armes et
au monde expérimente en ce moment ce qui
a permis évidemment de comment dirais-je
de faire passé l'effet de surprise d'un
camp à l'autre et en particulier dans
cette zone des trois frontières à la
entre au mali à la frontière avec le
burkina faso et le niger ou en fait bar
canard le concentré ses efforts et là en
début d'année le js qui est une qui
était en fait une franchise de dèche
dans cette région là avait marqué des
points contre notamment les armées
africaines sur place les contingents
africains maliens et nigériens les
bilans avait été sévère est en fait
l'état major des armées dit aujourd'hui
que le principe de
d'insécurité a été inversée
qu'aujourd'hui c'est barkan et ses
partenaires africains qui font régner la
sécurité sur sur cette katiba donc vous
voyez
plusieurs éléments à pour plus à
plusieurs titres en fait de prise en
main qu'on a raison de dire qu'il arrive
cette fois au sommet de nouakchott avec
des résultats est il d'ailleurs ces
résultats si vous voulez on les mesure
avec un certain nombre d'indicateurs on
peut dire par exemple les militaires
constatent par exemple qu'un certain
nombre de marchés qui avaient fermé dans
cette zone réouvre les populations
reviennent dans les villages on parle on
les militaires à ne pas trop donner des
chiffres mais on parle de plusieurs
centaines de jihadistes deux éliminés il
y a eu récemment plusieurs grands chefs
l'élimination le 3 juin dernier je vous
le rappel de de drogue dell qui est en
fait qui était qu'en fait le grand
patron de alors de la franchise d'al
qaïda au sahel qui était le numéro 3
d'al-qaïda mondiale qui a été éliminée
dans le nord du mali par une opération
des forces spéciales françaises sur
renseignement américain qui est une
belle victoire puisque c'était une
évidemment une cible de choix
alors voilà on en aidant et en fait on
se demande les experts et observateurs
se demandent de quel côté vont pencher
finalement vont balancer les cartes vont
être rebattues
c'est ces points marqués au niveau
militaire doivent maintenant être repris
et transformés sur le plan politique et
c'est là on en est là aujourd'hui et
j'avoue que c'est une grande inconnue
il y a plusieurs et il ya même un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes si on
regarde la scène régionale au niveau
politique les choses sont très
compliquées le président macro il ya
fait une toute petite allusion dans le
l'extrait de sa conférence de sa
déclaration que vous avez que vous avez
passé tout à l'heure peut-être la
première chose c'est que on ne sait pas
encore comment on fait les les
djihadistes au vent réagir aux coups de
boutoir que l'armée française leur a
fait subir dans le hall dans le sud dans
le sud est du mali donc de résoudre des
trois frontières
il se trouve que depuis le printemps en
fait les deux franchises concurrentes
dans cette région là se font la guerre
il se fond de guerre interne les
historiques ceux du nord mali qui sont
plutôt affiliés à al qaïda font la
guerre a donc à ceux dont je parlais
tout à l'heure qui sont plutôt un fille
a déj dans le sud est selon le bon vieux
principe des vases communicants quand
vous vous occupez de l'un l'autre et un
peu plus tranquille et le risque
évidemment c'est que cette franchise du
nord reprennent du poil de la bête est
aujourd'hui au centre de la photo dans
cette région on retrouve un un ancien
chef de guerre touareg qui équipiers qui
est un vétéran en fait de la rébellion
touareg qui est passé ensuite à l'islam
radical
iyad ag ghaly celui qui au printemps en
fait à à lancer des négociations avec
bamako
et c'est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle il ya eu des différends il ya
aujourd'hui des différends entre les
franchises donc cet homme-là qui est
évidemment aussi traqué par les armées
françaises depuis 2013 qui est toujours
passée sous les radars qu'on dit protégé
parallèle par l'algérie est aujourd'hui
celui qui a initié en fait une
négociation donc avec bamako ou en même
temps bamako en ce moment il ya des
problèmes entre le président imeca et
puis notamment un autre islamiste mais
un peu plus présentable lui qui
s'appelle dicko qui était le pendant
longtemps le patron du haut conseil
islamique me
maliens et qui aujourd'hui conteste le
pouvoir dit dit bk après avoir été son
allié voilà ces quelques mots pour vous
dire que le jeu politique est très
compliqué et on ne sait pas exactement
de quel côté peuvent pencher peut
pencher la balance
ça c'est vous merci beaucoup en tout cas
mériadec raffray pour ce point tout à
fait complet de la situation et de ce
sommet a ou b complet j'ai même pas eu
l'occasion vous poser une petite
question vous m'avez tous déroulé tout
seul c'est très bien merci en tout cas à
vous à l'occasion donc de la visite du
président macro mauritanie pour ce g5
scène merci à vous et on part maintenant
on réussit à la veille de la fin du
scrutin à constitutionnel vadimir
poutine a pris la parole tout à l'heure
lors d'une brève allocution télévisée le
président russe a expliqué l'importance
de la réforme constitutionnelle qui l'a
initié en janvier il a appelé tous les
citoyens à participer au référendum pour
garantir la stabilité la sécurité et la
prospérité du pays des précisions sur
base de notre correspondant antoine
clairon à la veille du dernier jour de
scrutin concernant ces changements ces
amendements apportés à la constitution
russe vladimir poutine était chargé f à
200 km à l'ouest de moscou afin
d'inaugurer un monument en l'honneur des
combattants tombés lors de cette grande
bataille de la seconde guerre mondiale
il en a profité au passage pour tenter
de mobiliser les électeurs qui ne se
sont pas encore rendus aux yeux nous
sommes face à un choix important il ne
s'agit pas seulement de normes
juridiques mais nous choisissons nous
faisons un choix vote pour le pays
le pays dans lesquelles nous avons
grandi pour plus de protection des
citoyens pour que les autorités puissent
rendre compte à la population dans un
pays dans lequel nous travaillons et que
nous voulons remettre à nos enfants et
je suis trouve un que chacun d'entre
vous participer à ce référendum en
pensant premièrement à ses proches
je remercie ceux qui ont déjà exprimé
leur choix et demain le 1er juillet sera
le jour principal du scrutin et je vous
demande chers amis de donner votre voix
chaque chaque voix chacun d'entre vous
est important
je vous remercie dans les faits les
changements à la constitution ont déjà
été adopté par le parlement
mais voilà avec ce scrutin vladimir
poutine cherche à donner une légitimité
populaire à cette réforme c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils se trouvent en
première ligne pour défendre ce vote et
pour convaincre les gens d'aller voter
et cela semble plutôt bien se présenter
d'après un sondage réalisé à la sortie
des urnes et publiés ce week-end pas
moins de trois votants sur quatre se
seraient prononcés en faveur des
amendements proposés voilà il reste
encore toute cette journée du 1er
juillet la journée principal de ce vote
pour confirmer ou au contraire infirmer
cette tendance mais aussi pour connaître
le taux de participation final reste
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du personnel hospitalier qui
manifestent aujourd'hui encore pour
demander davantage de moyens alors que
le ségur de la santé se termine ce
vendredi puis nous évoquons la fermeture
définitive de la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim en alsace une page se tourne
elle aura marqué le paysage politique et
économique français
[Musique]
donc
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck fallu que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent leur
personne non non non c'est pas vrai il
ya des climato si non ce n'est pas rien
à part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas
des chercheurs qui parlent que la presse
met en avant parce que il faut que du
débat mais il ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui il ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un
vrai bar une catastrophe ou va vers une
vraie catastrophe et on a incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense que les communes guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons bull est l'ennemi y'en
a pas d'ennemis l'ennemi ceni
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
date à ce trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on recevait à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
normal un débat éthique
[Musique]
en pleine crise du corona virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique
une véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et trônant la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
de bien choisir
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone azithromycine malgré
la polémique mondiale sur l'efficacité
de cette combinaison va le porter
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les dirty kids bien avant
que le match ne commence en effet par
sénégal la chloroquine de manière à les
utiliser pendant des décennies et des
décennies sa femme un père sourire
les sénégalais quand j'entends devenus
les offreurs et non il n'y a pas de
signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris toutes huile voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 30
juin
nouvelle journée d'action nationale des
personnels soignants des dizaines de
rassemblements étaient organisés un peu
partout en france à quelques jours de la
clôture du ségur de la santé les
médecins hospitaliers se sont joints au
cortège pas convaincu par les 300
millions d'euros de leurs salaires pour
deux pour leurs salaires pour poser hier
par le ministre de la santé en alsace
fin de partie pour fessenheim la plus
vieille centrale nucléaire française le
deuxième réacteur a été déconnecté du
réseau la semaine dernière c'est donc le
début d'un long processus de
démantèlement pour edf
alors la mise à l'arrêt de notre doyenne
est ce vraiment une bonne chose pour le
climat ou sonne-t-elle le glas de notre
souveraineté énergétique ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
de profond regret ils ont été exprimées
pour la première fois par le roi des
belges pour le passé colonial dans ce
qui s'appelait alors le congo pour la
première ministre l'heure est venue pour
la belgique d'entamer un parcours de
vérité une déclaration qui intervient
alors que la république démocratique du
congo fête les 60 ans de son
indépendance et dans le sillage de la
mort de l'afro américaine george floyd
qui a ravivé le débat sur les violences
[Musique]
sésame ouvre toi
les pays de l'ue ouvre les frontières de
l'union et de l'espace schengen à partir
de demain un voyageur d'une liste de 15
pays
elle comprend la chine mais sous
conditions est exclu pour l'instant les
états unis une liste établie en fonction
de la situation épidémiologique liés aux
coville jugée suffisamment sûre pour la
reprise des voyages
[Musique]
la mobilisation des personnels
hospitaliers nouveau dans la rue pour
réclamer davantage de moyens pour
l'hôpital des dizaines de rassemblements
ont eu lieu en france à paris le cortège
s'est élancé en début d'après-midi de
l'ancien hôpital militaire du
val-de-grâce direction le ministre de la
santé une manifestation autorisée par la
préfecture de police et une
manifestation en tout cas qui s'est
déroulée dans le calme les précisions de
notre reporter sur place katia technique
la journée d'action nationale des
soignants s'est terminée vers 17 heures
devant le ministère de la santé
le rassemblement a été organisé à
l'initiative de plusieurs syndicats cgt
fo unsa sud est ainsi que des collectifs
inter hôpitaux et inter urgence pour le
moment les syndicalistes se montrent
très mécontent des premières annonces du
ségur le ségur étant des concertations
organisées pour un plan massif de
revalorisation et d'investissement de
l'hôpital souhaité par le président
français or pour le moment
et bien ce qu'il en est ressorti ne
convainc pas par exemple le ministre de
la santé
olivier ferrand a annoncé une enveloppe
de 6 milliards pour augmenter les
personnels soignants pour des
revalorisations de salaires des
infirmières des aides soignants des
manipulateurs radio
or cela ne suffit pas je vous propose
d'écouter les secrétaires nationaux des
fo et de la cgt y verriez et philippe
martinez à ce sujet on reprend avec les
politiques d'avant or j'avais cru
comprendre que l'après ne serait pas
comme avant et en particulier en matière
de santé le président la république lui
même a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
considérer la santé comme une seule
variable financière et bien il faut
qu'on cesse avec ses politiques et si on
reprend les politiques d'avant bah ça
n'ira pas ça c'est clair donc il faut
qu'on revienne là-dessus
plus le gouvernement
donne des aides accorde des prêts aux
entreprises et plus il ya des
suppressions d'emplois j'avais cru
comprendre que ces aides ces prêts
c'était non seulement c'était pour
maintenir au moins maintenir l'emploi
voir le développer donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on est reparti comme
avant quoi c'est des licenciements
boursiers
parce qu'on pense d'abord aux
actionnaires et puis l'emploi les
salariés les citoyens ça passe après la
mobilisation parisienne sous escorte
policière s'est déroulée dans le calme
les participants à cette manifestation
en temps de peser sur les négociations
du ségur alors leurs revendications ils
les portent déjà depuis quasiment deux
ans c'est à dire évidemment des
augmentations de salaire mais également
des recrutements l'arrêt des fermetures
de lits des restructurations une
meilleure qualité d'accueil pour les
malades et toutes ces revendications et
bien selon eux n'étaient pas vraiment
abordés durant le ségur où tout cas pas
suffisamment
voici pourquoi il était dans la rue
aujourd'hui et pour en parler nous
sommes avec thierry amouroux un
infirmier ap-hp porte parole du syndicat
infirmier snp
merci d'être avec nous qui avons rouge
avait une hésitation pardonnez-moi sur
l'intitulé de votre syndicat pardonnez
moi alors on tant que soignant vous avez
évidemment participer et suivi cette
forte journée de mobilisation
on sait que ça fait des mois et des mois
que vous vous mobilisez il y aura des
annonces demain il y en a déjà eu est ce
que vous y croyez encore que ce type de
rassemblement puisse infléchir la
position du ministre oui tout à fait et
si les hôpitaux sont revenus sur le
devant de la scène c'est parce que il ya
la population à soutenir fortement les
soignants et a souhaité que l'hôpital
puisse répondre aux besoins de santé de
la population
parce que ça fait des années que l'on
ferme des lits que l'on supprime des
postes
donc aujourd'hui et bien sûr la
manifestation à paris des parisiens mais
surtout il ya eu presque amy lee hye et
de rassemblements dans toute la france
elle même dans les petits départements
ruraux
vous aviez six ou sept villes qui
étaient mobilisés donc voilà les gens
ont compris que lors de la crise covin
on avait que 5 me lit de réanimation
france l'allemagne on a les 25000 5 fois
plus
du coup on a eu quatre fois plus de
morts que l'allemagne
donc chacun a bien compris qu'il fallait
avoir un nombre suffisant de deux lits
pour répondre aux besoins de la
population
et là on voit bien qu'il ya un fort
soutien
les gens après les applaudissements aux
fenêtres sont aujourd'hui dans la rue à
nos côtés on voit bien dans tous les
cortèges dans toute la france qui avait
eu autant d'usagés que de deux blouses
blanches dans dans ces rassemblements et
ça fait chaud au coeur
chacun a compris le problème de la crise
de l'hôpital alors série à mon collègue
que les citoyens français compris ça on
n'en doutait pas vraiment mais la
question c'est est-ce que
ministre lui at il entendu non pas du
tout c'est d'ailleurs très très
inquiétant parce que nous ce que l'on
constate sur le terrain c'est que bas
depuis le déconfinement on continue à
fermer des lits il ya le y compris au
niveau symbolique au niveau du chu de
strasbourg il ya quatorze lits de
réanimation qui ont été supprimés alors
qu'on en manquait tellement dans le
grand test et ils vous avez dans toute
la france
beaucoup d'hôpitaux ou les directions
profite de cette phase pour ne pas
rouvrir les lits qui avait été fermée
pendant la phase kovy devons concentrer
les moyens sur les salles où on
s'occuper des patients que vides en
fermant les autres salles d'intervention
programmés et il est donc c'est un vrai
vrai problème parce que il ya eu un pic
de mortalité liée au co vide mais là le
risque clair c'est par rapport aux gens
qui ont des pathologies chroniques ou
qu'ils avaient des interventions
programmées mais non urgentes
donc tous ses passions que l'on a par
suivisme au mois de mars avril mai
on pensait les prendre on sûr plus en
juillet août
or on nous ferme des lits et donc nous
sommes obligés de décommander des
patients qui étaient prévus sur juillet
août alors que le il faudrait qu'on
puisse prendre ce qui avait été
décommandé pendant la phase covin donc
il ya un vrai décalage entre les besoins
de santé de la population et est ce
qu'une administration un peu folle nous
oblige à faire en enfermant des délices
qui est totalement incompréhensible
rapidement 6 milliards d'euros quand
même pour revaloriser vos salaires
jamais un effort aussi grand n'avait été
fait c'est c'est vraiment pas suffisant
on vous admettez quand même qu' il ya eu
voilà des concessions de la part du
gouvernement alors 6 milliards d'euros
pour 1,2 million de fonctionnaires à
l'hôpital et 500 mille salariés de la
santé dans le privé donc 6 milliards
pour un million sept
je vous donnerai l'exemple de air france
ou de renom qui ont eu 5 et 7 milliards
pour 45 et 48 mille agents
donc on voit bien le décalage il faut
bien comprendre que quand même depuis 10
ans les gouvernements successifs ont
retiré 11,3 milliards au budget de la
santé qui ont fait 84 dont plus de 10 %
de notre budget a été amputé ces
dernières années donc 6 milliards c'est
une goutte d'eau par rapport à à la
dette accumulée par les gouvernements
successifs depuis dix ans thierry
amouroux et agnès buzyn s'est longuement
exprimé devant la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
la question des masses vous concerne
directement vous les soignants elle a
expliqué qu'en gros le gouvernement
n'était pas vraiment responsable et des
commandes que c'était des commandes sim
et de la gestion des stocks non puisque
c'est l agence de santé régional est ce
qu'elle vous a convaincu l'ex ministre
de la santé aujourd'hui sur la gestion
de la crise et notamment sur cette
question des masques qui vous concerne
pas du tout elle est totalement
responsable et coupable à la fois de ne
pas avoir tenu compte du rapport de 2018
qui indiquait qu'il manquait des masques
et qu'il fallait ont commandé et le fait
que à nous écrit perdre deux mois
cruciaux où elle n'a rien fait et rien
commandé donc bon c'est sûr que vu le
poids de sa culpabilité et les milliers
de morts 1 qu'il y a eu qui aurait pu
être évitable et qui sont liées à cette
décision lorsqu'on a autant de morts sur
la conscience on n'est pas un parjure
près donc voila mais ce qui est
dramatique c'est que elle continue de
d'être complètement à côté de la plaque
enfin bon de guillot oui on était en
avance sur ce qui était guy au niveau
international alors que l'om est dès
février 10 fr où il faut tester tester
tester que depuis 100 ans
on sait que lorsqu'il ya une maladie
respiratoire et b il faut avoir des
masques qui avait un milliard cinq cent
mille le masque
au moment de l'achat ena et qu' il y en
avait plus que 200 millions
enfin à fin 2010 8 enfin bon on voit un
gâchis incroyable et une faute très
lourde à la fois de la ministre des
cabinets ministériels et des hauts
fonctionnaires et c'est pour ça que vous
avez les 63 plaintes qui sont en cours
des plaintes pénales et des plaintes
devant la haute cour de justice et
qu'ils auront à répondre de ce scandale
merci beaucoup thierry amouroux d'avoir
été avec mon direct sur rt france des
centrales nucléaires françaises a été
définitivement arrêté ce sont grands
réacteurs a été débranché du réseau
électrique national hier soir le début
d'un long processus de démantèlement
mais un sentiment de victoire pour les
militants antinucléaires français et
allemands ils ont ce livre est
d'ailleurs ensemble l'événement dans
l'après-midi à bord dans le béton sur le
rhin on a un peu le triomphe sobre parce
que c'est une étape il y a encore 56
autres réacteurs a fermé pour l'instant
on en prend malheureusement pas le
chemin
et donc il faut continuer à se battre
encore on ne sait pas comment on
démantèle aujourd'hui donc ça va générer
beaucoup de difficultés et il faudra que
les associations soient toujours
présente pour vérifier que non seulement
on irradie pas la nature qu'on ne
disperse pas de la radioactivité mais qu
on irradie pas les travailleurs
fessenheim aura donc marqué le paysage
politique économique française
retour en images sur les dernières
grandes étapes qui ont abouti à son
arrêt définitif
[Musique]
m
monte
[Musique]
non
vous
m
[Musique]
il
on va dire c'est une très petite
victoire parce que pour que la france
sorte du nucléaire comme le font les
allemands juste en face de nous on est
mal barré c'est pareil les conditions
dans laquelle elles ferment ce n'est pas
du tout une victoire
le gouvernement comme edf se sont très
bien entendus pour faire comprendre que
ça va coûter très cher on parle de
milliards de de dédommagement pour aider
f ce qu'il n'aurait pas lieu d'être
légalement
[Musique]
et
on
vie économique du tout le secteur va en
pâtir
c'est évident a eu des magasins des
restaurants c'est parce que ça va
devenir nos biens immobiliers est ce que
les prix vont baisser ou pas
[Musique]
et alors l'arrêt de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim est ce vraiment
une bonne chose pour le climat ou suntil
le glas de notre souveraineté
énergétique
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec gérard onesta élus et europe
ecologie les verts président du bureau
de l'assemblée du conseil régional
d'occitanie bonsoir avons gérard onesta
à ses côtés georges kiejman au beach
présidents de républiques souveraines
bonsoir à vous également georges madame
bonsoir être avec nous alors cette
centrale un été en service quand même
depuis 1977 elle a été définitivement
débrancher vous êtes satisfait cette
décision gérard onesta
écoutez c'est un début si on en reste là
ça ne sert quasiment à rien mais
effectivement il fallait commencer par
une centrale autant commencer or la plus
ancienne potentiellement dangereuses
mais je vous rappelle que pour tenir les
engagements de la france
il va falloir un démanteler maintenant
deux parents pendant 15 ans jean-jacques
osmanovic vous quelle est votre réaction
après l'arrêt de cette centrale il
fallait le faire il fallait sûrement
travailler sur les anciennes centrales
nucléaires et en construire d'autres de
manière globale ce qui se passe est un
problème et pour la souveraineté et pour
le climat mais je rappellerai que si
nous fermons les centrales nucléaires en
france
nous passerons soit à des énergies dites
renouvelables c'est à dire d énergie
solaire ou éolienne qui consomme
énormément d'énergie carbonée je pense
je crois que les batteries est ce qu'il
ya de pire en terme de pollution sur
notre pauvre planète
et comme le giec lui même le rappeler le
groupement d'experts
intergouvernementaux qui travaillent sur
l'évolution du climat
l'atom est la solution peut-être
principal pour sortir du drame
international dans lequel nous nous
trouvons
car cette énergie ne sera pas remplacé
que part de l'éolien et du solaire bien
évidemment elle sera remplacée comme en
allemagne par du charbon
d'une part nous perdons notre
souveraineté
un fleuron industriel français depuis
marie curie alors qu'il y a d'énormes
possibilités
par exemple ce gouvernement je pense
d'ailleurs c'était une satisfaction de
élevé une satisfaction de certains
autres écologistes a arrêté les
recherches sur les réacteurs de
quatrième génération
ce sont des rails c'était le projet
astrid c'est à dire les réacteurs qui
fonctionne sur les déchets des centrales
actuelles
l'uranium appauvri le plutonium dont qui
permettait d'avoir des déchets de longue
vie ont beaucoup moins grand nombre mais
nous avons abandonné alors que les
chinois les russes les américains eux
continuent donc je ne comprends pas du
tout quel jour on peut avoir à perdre un
fleuron encore industriels à
l'abandonner à un vent de notre
souveraineté à ne pas participer au
règlement du problème climatique de la
planète
gérard onesta ya plusieurs idées dans ce
que raconte georges kauffmann aux vitres
on va parler de la souveraineté plaies
après mais c'est vrai que ce qui revient
souvent c'est par quoi on remplace
effectivement cette énergie de produisez
fait celle là il me c'est bien moi
vouloir arrêter le nucléaire mais
parfois on le remplace d'abord je peux
pas laisser dire que le nucléaire ne
crée 0 gacé faîtière parce que pour
extraire le minerai
on le transforme le transporter pour
créer les centrales qui sont des mètres
cubes des mètres cubes de béton qui sont
des gros consommateurs de gaz à effet de
serre le bilan le bilan carbone du
nucléaire n'est pas égal à zéro loin
s'en faut
je suis je veux pas entendre non plus
que le parmi les déchets les plus
dangereux il y aurait les batteries
c'est que les batteries s'ils ne sont
pas votre retraités sont dangereuses
mais comparé la dangerosité en durée de
vie d'une batterie au combustible
nucléaire ou là on va empoisonner la
planète pour des milliers d'années
je pense qu'il faut quand même garder le
sens du raisonnable
par contre en place le nucléaire est
bien par beaucoup de choses d'abord une
énergie qu'elle pas trop les élus autant
je suis une élue mais beaucoup d
traditionnel n'aime pas c'était cette
énergie là parce qu'il ne veut pas
l'inaugurer ce sont les économies
d'énergie une économie d'énergie au coût
que jamais le cordon et pourtant avoir
habité dans un bâtiment qui consomme
deux fois moins d'énergie prendre des
transports qui co qui consomme deux fois
moins d'énergie mais d'un seul coup on
règle la moitié du problème et ensuite
tout simplement bien il faut regarder le
bouquet je dis bien le bouquet complet
des énergies renouvelables et des pays
qui ont des liens mais pas de biomasse
de l'hydraulique pas de géothermique
mais nous lâche france cocorico on a la
chance on a le bouquet complet
finalement la seule énergie qui nous
manque c'est l'énergie politique ça les
écologistes eux l'ont alors y'en a un
autre puisque vous parlez de politique
que ça va on emballe pas vraiment cet
arrêt de fessenheim c'est le ministre de
l'économie
écoutez la réaction de bruno le maire ce
matin confrère le nucléaire n'émet pas
de co2
c'est une énergique deux avantages elle
nous permet d'être l'un des pays qui
émet le moins de co2 pour sa production
d'électricité
et ça nous garantit notre indépendance a
effectivement georges kiejman a vite
c'était un point que vous sauviez tout à
l'heure la question de l'indépendance
très à la mode en ce moment
effectivement la souveraineté vous
abondez on imagine dans le sens de bruno
le maire oui enfin je suis pas convaincu
que monsieur bruno le maire avait
réellement défendre la souveraineté
nationale et en particulier
industrielles non plus tôt j'ai plutôt
prouvé le contraire ce sont encore une
fois des mots je voudrais revenir sur ce
que vous avez dit monsieur je n'ai pas
dit que c'était là les batteries étaient
les plus dangereuses c'est bien
évidemment absurde
le plus dangereux c'est dans l'absolu en
danger immédiat c'est nucléaire j'ai dit
que c'était le plus polluant c'est deux
choses différentes et vous avez parlé
d'extraction de minerais bien évidemment
ça coûte de l'énergie et ça consomme
mais vous savez très bien bien moins que
l'extraction de terres rares que nous
refusons enfers en france car nous
pouvions le faire parce que vous savez
parfaitement que c'est extrêmement
polluant donc on peut le faire chez les
autres la barre des pays en asie et pour
la corée du nord
et puis la corée du nord est un des
grands producteurs de terreur qui passe
par la chine seront sur n'occupe pas
c'est pas grave ça pollue ça peut lui
dans sa peau lui dans ce coin du monde
et toutes façons des batteries ne pollue
pas bien évidemment en france elles
polluent l'inde le bangladesh la chine
ou le vietnam sur sûr ici c'est vrai que
je suis malheureusement c'est comme ça
avoue que c'est serena van ga lisant le
mécénat bouchehr contradicteurs je suis
allé sur place voir le problème
et croyez bien que je les dénonce et
avec moins de temps deviendra ce que
vous différencier patrimoine c'est moi
qui suis allé sur place
pourtant c'était en corée du nord mais
moi aussi je sais pas encore une énorme
excusez moi tu aller ailleurs mais sur
la la souveraineté industrielle est en
même temps le règlement du problème de
l'émission de co2 parce que encore une
fois je pense que nous sommes d'accord
que c'est le problème principal évoqué
par le giec dans tous les grands
problèmes environnementaux que nous
affrontons avec celui de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité
nous avions des solutions en france en
conservant la souveraineté industrielle
un exemple nous aurions pu conserver que
nous pouvons d'ailleurs toujours
récupérer si nous avions la volonté
politique comme vous le disiez de
récupérer alstom est ainsi que les
turbines qui font tourner nos centrales
nucléaires ainsi que nos sous-marins et
notre porte-avions nucléaire de
renationaliser la ssr ne remette des
lignes suffisantes verticalement et
horizontalement de faire comme fait la
suisse qui ne sont pas quittes un pays
tout à fait intéressant dans ce domaine
là puisque vous avez affaire otages
quasi totale et vous avez énormément de
petites lignes tout à fait accessible
pour les panthères en termes de prix
pour leurs citoyens
et vous auriez une politique donc global
de réduction du co2 avec ses trains
alimenté par l'énergie nucléaire et si
bien une chose qui pose problème dans un
reportage qui était faite lorsque vous
avez dit monsieur c'est bien évidemment
que c'est une c'est quelque chose qui
est dangereux qui demande un accord
global avec les citoyens et ce que l'on
ne peut pas faire c'est avoir des
entreprises sous traitantes
on n'a vu qu'une partie des problèmes
en particulier fissures dans les cuves
venait de l'intervention d'entreprises
sous traitantes
mais là c'est une logique néolibérale et
monsieur renaud niger si je peux vous
apporter la contradiction parce que le
temps qui nous reste est très court je
vais commencer par dire qu'il n'y a pas
moins garant de l'indépendance nationale
que l'uranium qu'ils aient un rôle
essentiel des pays étrangers dont
certains je pense à l'afrique
subsaharienne sont particulièrement
instable et non je pense que si la
france intervient au sahel s'est
peut-être pas simplement pour contrer la
menace islamique mais aussi pour
protéger sa ligne au visionnement de son
carburant nucléaire tout comme les us
ste hélène au moyen-orient pour
sécuriser le marché de leurs prêts
précieux pétrole donc à pas moins garant
de l'indépendance nationale que
l'uranium
ensuite le le coût du nucléaire
le coût du nucléaire le jour en paiera
le kilowatt nucléaire a sombré prix et
bien je peux vous dire que tout le reste
sera extrêmement compétitif parce que le
nucléaire est la seule énergie où la
recherche est porté par les finances
publiques les assurances il n'y a pas
d'assurances regardez vos contrats
d'assurance et un tout petit est assuré
contre tout sauf contre les risques de
fission des atomes le démantèlement les
approvisionnements les provisionnements
financiers sont absolument ridicules et
la gestion des déchets etc au siècle
passé d'eau sur le plan financier c'est
également une escroquerie
je parle même pas des milliards qu'on
avait pensé en vain pour le p r le nôtre
mais celui également que nous avons
vendu à ses ports finlandais qui ne
savent qu'en terme ce qui ne marche
toujours pas ces milliards là je peux
vous dire il en crée des lignes de
chemin de fer dont good on vous parle et
qui fonctionnera avec l'électricité qui
ne sera pas aussi dangereuse est aussi
coûteuse que celle coupe défendu
clairement la fermeture de fessenheim
est en tout cas est une étape 1 pour
certains on a eu plusieurs invités cet
après midi dont des militants du réseau
sortir du nucléaire qui ne compte pas en
rester là et compte essayer de faire
fermer d'autres centrales georges
kossmann au beach pour vous ce serait
vraiment une catastrophe pour la france
qu'il ne faut pas céder à cela car non
j'ai dit pourquoi ce serait une
catastrophe pour plusieurs raisons sur
ce que vous venez venez de dire monsieur
je vais très très vite mais vous n'avez
pas répondu sur le fait que le giec
encore une fois invite à trouver
considère que la thomas est une solution
effectivement les déchets nucléaires
sont un problème c'est pour ça qu'il est
tout à fait étonnant encore une fois je
le répète et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi les écologistes s'opposent à
cela que nous arrivait nous c'est sur la
recherche sur les général sur les
générateurs de quatrième génération qui
veut perdre ni réacteurs pardon de
quatrième génération qui me permettrait
de fonctionner sur les déchets des
réacteurs actuels du coup de magie ni
l'argent bien sûr
et est-ce que vous avez comptabiliser le
coût que représente pour l'allemagne que
représentera pour la france et que
représente pour la planète
l'utilisation de ce qui est toujours
l'énergie la plus utilisée dans le monde
c'est-à-dire le charbon est ce que c'est
quand il fait envoyer vos chiffres la
production de charbon s'écroule en
allemagne elle s'écroule regarder les
courses
elle s'écroule c'est là et on met un
consommateur de nous parce qu'ils ont
isolé beaucoup plus que nous toujours la
question des économies d'énergie
regardez vous avez raison vous avez
raison pour ça bien évidemment on est
entièrement d'accord il faut isoler et
consommer moins c'est bien évident merci
merci en tout cas à tous les deux le
débat demanderait encore davantage de
temps mais en tout cas voilà on a
compris en tout cas vos idées
respectives merci gérard onesta merci à
vous également george kaufmann au beach
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du roi des belges inquiet
pour la première fois exprimé des
regrets pour le passé colonial de la
couronne en république démocratique du
congo et puis sur un ton plus léger nous
parlerons à des destinations pour les
vacances alors que l'union européenne
rouvre en partie ses frontières à 15
pays
demain les français s'interrogent où
iront ils passaient leurs vacances d'été
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qu'un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse cet ordre
mondial on essaie de le faire perdurer
mais on est à la fin d'un modèle qui
était le tout misé sur la dette
tu es la dette et la relance par la
dette ou par la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est en imprimant des billets
que vous relancer une économie si on
essaie autant de relancer la croissance
économique s'est fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire ça en france on
s'est connus je peux pas continuer à
diffuser des chiffres qui sont
absolument faux simplement parce que ça
arrange monsieur trump à ce moment là
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france c'est le premier souverain
régnant à exprimer publiquement ses
regrets pour la période coloniale
dans une lettre adressée au président de
la république démocratique du congo le
roi philippe regrette je cite ces
blessures du passé
un courrier qui coïncide avec le 60ème
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la rdc
le roi des belges y affirme son
engagement à combattre toutes les formes
de racisme
en belgique la mort de georges floyd a
ravivé le débat sur le rôle de léopold
ii deux accusés d'avoir tué des millions
de congolais des actes de violence peu
condamne leur watch notre histoire est
faite de réalisation commune mais a
aussi connu des épisodes douloureux à
l'époque de l'état indépendant du congo
des actes de violence et de cruauté ont
été commis qui pèsent encore sur notre
mémoire collective
la période coloniale qui a suivi a
également causé des souffrances et des
humiliations
je tiens à exprimer mes plus profond
regret pour ses blessures du passé dont
la douleur est aujourd'hui ravivées par
les discriminations encore trop présente
dans nos sociétés est ce qu'on propose à
des côtes et la réaction des
ressortissants belges à notre micro
je trouve que c'est une bonne initiative
maintenant il va falloir savoir
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour le quotidien voilà de la population
congolaise de tous les ressortissants et
les voilà les enfants de la diaspora
parler c'est bien mais les axes anciens
encore mieux et donc il ya des actions
vraiment concrètes a à faire vraiment
pour prouver que que dès que les excuses
et que des regrets sont sont d'ordre
voilà c'est une bonne chose c'est vrai
que voilà c'est peut-être un peu tard
mais en soi c'est une bonne chose mais
concrètement qu'est ce que ça change la
situation actuelle par rapport à
notamment la discrimination par rapport
au racisme et effectivement je pense
qu'il ya un manque d'éducation notamment
à l'école sur l'histoire du colonialisme
et ça ça devrait quelque chose qui
devrait être complètement dans le
programme scolaire parce que beaucoup de
belges ne connaissent pas l'histoire de
la colonisation ne connaissent pas
l'histoire de enfin des conséquences
actuelles à l'heure actuelle la plupart
des pays africains souffrent encore de
la colonisation il
jamais trop tard on va dire est que je
trouve qu'il devrait faire plus de
choses pour montrer on va dire son
regret est que la belgique déjà doit
s'excuser ce qu'elle a fait publiquement
mais aussi avec des actes que c'est bien
les mots mais il faut des actes et pour
en parler nous sommes avec nive bernard
des billets avocats belges bonsoir
bernard démis merci elle est vrai qu en
direct sur arte france s'est exclu ses
excuses c'est une première pour
l'histoire de la belgique clairement
bonjour madame il s'agit d' à peu près
tout sauf des excuses mais d un profond
regret a été a été donnée mais qu'il n'y
a pas d'excusé mode excuses ne sont pas
prononcés par le roi est intéressant
d'ailleurs de voir dans cette lettre qui
est une lette vous l'avez rappelé qu' et
qui est une initiative personnelle du
roi des belges
l'initiative oms il faut tempérer
évidemment en belgique le le roi règne
mais ne gouverne pas donc c'est
totalement sous contrôle du gouvernement
mais c'est une initiative personnelle ce
sont des regrets qui sont expliquées par
des excuses
il est intéressant de voir que on ne
mentionne pas le nom de léopold 2 la
colonisation n'est pas plus jugé il est
plutôt question d'un passé douloureux
commun si le mot commun qui revient le
plus donc il ne s'agit pas d' excuses
c'est une lettre d'une grande
intelligence d'une grande finesse
j'aimerais que c'est ce qu'on puisse
retenir c'est là qu'elle va répondre aux
cinq sens vous avez raison on va s'y
arrêter parce que ça veut dire selon
vous qui
ne va pas finalement nous voilà en
général quand on regrette des blessures
du passé
le pendant serait peut-être de s'excuser
ou pas d'ailleurs en tout cas clairement
pour vous la subtilité ici est à noter
et elle a un sens oui à nouveau c'est
une lettre d'une grande finesse d'une
grande intelligence à laquelle répond
d'ailleurs de manière aussi intelligente
est aussi fine le président de la
république démocratique du congo
il n'y a pas de demande d'excusés de la
part du congo le président ne l'a pas
demandé et lorsqu'il reçoit cette lettre
il y répond ce sens remercie ya pas de
remerciements pour les regrets il y a la
volonté qui est exprimé par le par le
président n'avait pas prévu ligue
démocratique du congo de parler
d'histoire à nos enfants de cette
histoire qui est une histoire commune et
sur base d'un travail scientifique
commun donc c'est vraiment la
continuation continuation pardon d'une
histoire commune c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir
même si des regrets sont son sang sont
évoqués pour pour ce qui est d'aider des
souffrances des bébés cruauté le mot
kloet et ans est employé mais nous ne
sommes pas dans les excuses
sept autres acheter plus fins et plus
intelligent c'est peut-être la seule
faille d'ailleurs c'est la finesse et
l'intelligence qui est rarement bien
comprise alors les atrocités des crimes
coloniaux sadique quelque chose en tout
cas sur sur l'histoire puisque c'est
très rare effectivement qu'un
gouvernement car croire c'est une
première madame née à nouveau les mots
ont un sens vous lisiez vous même
il parle des actes de violence et de
cruauté qui ont été commis il n'y a pas
de généralisations donc on n'est
vraiment pas dans un système de
repentance ce qu'on ne t'a pas à un coup
de grands marteau que c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus fin plus intelligence la
relation entre la belgique et le congo
est une relation qui vaut mieux que ddd
des stéréotypes qui vaut mieux que que
ce genre d'affirmation il n'empêche ces
regrets ont été formulées à dans un
climat de tension notamment aux états
unis
et ont ramené le débat sur le passé
notamment des empires coloniaux sur la
table en tout cas en belgique admettre
publiquement que les pays colonisés on
souffert ont été spoliés est ce que ça
peut clairement permettre d'apaiser le
climat
alors qu il n'y pas de questions de
spoliation c'est important parce que
vous voyez même dans le languedoc dans
ce que nous disons aux vous et moi
notre discussion est polluée par des
mots qu'on a entendu qu'ils sont qui
sont rattachés alors à longueur de
journée il n'est pas question de deux
explications à titre personnel je jamais
9 ans d'avoir les compétences est un
sujet délicat et je me garderai bien
effectivement de refaire l'histoire et
si la réponse la réponse qui est donnée
à nouveau la lettre est intelligente
fine la réponse est intelligente et fine
ce sont des déclarations aussi bien du
roi des belges que du président du congo
qui sont des déclarations ou bi et orbi
si vous voulez à la cité au reste du
monde
on voit très bien qu'il parle leur
propre peuple qui parle aussi au peuple
en face de la belgique ou le congo est
la référence qui est fait par le par le
président du congo est intéressant parce
qu'il vit qu'il faut parler à nos
enfants mais sur base d'un travail
scientifique commun ça veut donc dire
que il parle notamment la diaspora
africaine dont quelques représentants
ont été présentés dans votre petit sujet
avant en leur disant on doit parler de
l'histoire de notre histoire commune
mais sur base d'un travail scientifique
on ne peut pas dire tout et n'importe
quoi et c'est vrai que les tensions dont
vous parliez ont fait émerger des propos
totalement faut donc un travail
scientifique commun une histoire commune
et à nouveau c'est un moment je pense
extrêmement important qui montre si la
personnalité royal vous savez en
belgique le roi n'a pas beaucoup
l'occasion d'exprimer à nouveau il ne
gouverne pas et on voit chez lui une
grande finesse et juste que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est que la réponse du
congo est à la hauteur fine et
intelligente c'est ça que j'aimerais que
l'on puisse retenir ce soir puisque vous
l'avez dit en tout cas plusieurs fois
comment on réagit
et les belges cette sortie de leur roi
écoutez je crois qu'il est un peu tôt
pour le dire et à nouveau jeudi le
souvent le débat est un peu pollué par
des mots un peu outrancier de telle
sorte qu'on est amené à prendre des
positions sans avoir lu je ne savais pas
quelles seraient vos questions donc je
m'apprêtais à lire la déclaration royal
vous l'avez vous l'avez fait
vous l'avez fait pour moi et ont donc
sans cette lecture sur cette
compréhension c'est difficile de réagir
mais je crois que cette déclaration est
très très bien très bien reçus
évidemment parce que merci beaucoup il
veut avoir des vies d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur air france alors que
la pandémie de kobe 19 vient de franchir
le seuil symbolique de plus d'un demi
million de morts dans le nom de l'union
européenne annonce la réouverture de ces
frontières à 15 pays dont la chine sous
condition états unis exclu
l'organisation mondiale de la santé l
alerte à la pandémie est loin d'être
finie elle a par ailleurs annoncé hier
l'envoi la semaine prochaine d'une
équipe en chine pour tenter de
comprendre comment la maladie a débuté l
oms appelle également le monde à se
mobiliser sans attendre un vaccin avec
10 millions de cas et un demi million de
décès le pire est encore à venir
si nous nous attaquons pas aux problèmes
que nous avons déjà identifié à savoir
le manque d'unité nationale et de
solidarité mondiale et un monde divisé
qui contribuent en fait à la propagation
du virus
comme je le dis dans mon discours
le pire est à venir je suis désolé de le
dire mais avec ce genre d'environnement
et de conditions nous craignons de
pirate wifi nous pouvons mieux combattre
le virus si nous savons tout sur le
virus y compris comment il a commencé
ici sending team
next week nous enverrons une équipe la
semaine prochaine en chine pour préparer
cela et nous espérons que cela nous
permettra de comprendre comment le virus
a commencé timing est ce que nous
pouvons faire à l'avenir pour nous
préparer tout et l'ouverture des
frontières signifie pour certains la
possibilité également de voyager alors
où les français pourront ils aller cet
été avec quelles contraintes quelles
destinations vont sortir leur épingle du
jeu pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec caroline
seigneur responsable d'une agence de
voyages au travail corner dans le 7e
arrondissement à paris bon soir caroline
seigneur merci d'être avec nous alors
l'europe qui rouvre ses frontières mais
l'om est ce qui reste malgré tout
pessimiste vous en tant que responsable
d'agencé qu'est ce que vous dites à vos
clients aujourd'hui est ce que vous y
voyez un peu plus clair vous même mais
en fait ça dépend de comment vous dire
en fonction des pays dans lesquels les
clients comptent aller on essaie de se
renseigner en fonction des mesures
prises qui en place par chaque
gouvernement et on prend les décisions
au jour le jour
alors effectivement la liste et eve
dévoyer les dayaks 15 pays qui sont
c'était aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
français mais on prévient qu'elle peut
être réviser toutes les deux semaines ça
veut dire beaucoup d'incertitudes même
autour de ces destinations
beaucoup d'incertitudes parce que par
exemple je vais prendre le nom qui est
l'exemple de la grèce
il ya encore une semaine on savait que
la grèce était et est prête à ouvrir à
partir du 1er juillet sauf que là donc
depuis hier ils ont mis en place un
système de questionnaire avec un qr code
que les clients devront avoir à leur
arrivée et ça déterminera s'ils doivent
être testés donc vous voyez c'est tous
les jours des nouvelles des nouvelles
mises en place
par les pays c'est un petit peu
difficile à à mettre fin à expliquer aux
clients si vous voulez ça augmente leur
crainte je trouve et pour nous aussi
parce que néanmoins c'est pas facile
parce qu'il faut pouvoir le gérer pour
toutes les destinations en tout cas pour
ma part moi je fais le monde entier donc
il faut se renseigner pour chaque pays
du monde entier alors il ya quinze
destinations effectivement que n'ont
rien à voir les unes que les autres jeux
j'en suis quelques-unes l'algérie
l'australie le canada la géorgie le
ronde à la serbie la corée du sud la
thaïlande tunisie uruguay pour vous en
tant qu agence de voyages est ce qu'il
ya une logique qui est respectée dans
ces destinations non encore une fois
c'est la france qui prend la décision
d'accueillir les résidents de ces
destinations comme l'australie le rwanda
ou d'autres destinations que vous avez
pu évoquer par contre ça veut pas dire
que les autres destinations enfin je
vous prends l'exemple de l'australie par
exemple ça veut pas dire que les
australiens eux auront droit de quitter
leur pays pour venir en europe
nous on va les accepter mais sous
certaines conditions
mais par contre les australiens eux
n'auront pas droit quitter le pays c'est
important de le préciser exactement
aujourd'hui clairement quels sont les
pays un petit peu tout terrain où les
français ne prendrons pas de risque pour
leurs vacances
je dirais l'espagne l'italie la france
bien sûr
après ça peut être la belgique ce peut
être l'allemagne c'est peut-être le
moment de découvrir des destinations on
n'aurait pas l'habitude mais voilà je
dirais plutôt en tout cas ces derniers
jours les clients quand même beaucoup de
craintes
donc je dois avouer que il est
préférable peut-être de rester dans
l'espace schengen pour le moment guen ou
carrément la france c'était en tout cas
le souhait du gouvernement
clairement aujourd'hui les français
affichent leur préférence pour leur
propre pays où ils ne se sont pas encore
en majorité décidée pour leurs vacances
d'été
pas touche pas tous y en a beaucoup qui
sont pris
à réserver pour enfin en dehors de la
france
par contre ça va plus tout est du las
minutes je pense c'est à dire devenu
lastminute les gens vont vraiment se
décider au tout dernier moment avec
peut-être des tarifs préférentiels ou au
contraire les hôteliers vont vouloir
peut-être se rattraper de leurs pertes à
quoi doit-on s'attendre au niveau des
tarifs au niveau des tarifs c'est
possible que des prix baissent apprécié
selon certaines destinations si vous
prenez par exemple la grèce par contre
je doute que les plus vraiment baisse
sachant que des dés par exemple les
allemands ou les roumains et les russes
sont très sont très enclins à aller en
grèce et pour le coup le prix je doute
que ça les frênes vraiment par contre
pour les français c'est pas tant une
question de prix c'est une question
plutôt de santé les conditions dans
lesquelles ils peuvent être amenés à
être être accepté par le pays si c'est
pour aller en grèce une semaine deux
semaines
et puis à l'arrivée on vous dit que vous
avez un test à faire et que nous est
positif il va falloir ferrer n 14 est
loué en septaine ouais on imagine que ce
n'est pas évident clairement haut niveau
voilà pas tarifs mais au niveau quand on
a pris un voyage c'est extrêmement
compliqué on imagine les conditions de
remboursement comment ça se passe
comment vous gérez ça vous en tant
qu'agence il ya des décrets on suppose
mais c'est compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
alors après il yal ordonnance du 25 mars
qui qui régule les les voyages à forfait
donc les clients qui ont réservé des
volailles des vols avec avec hôtel après
pour nous c'est une scène une
négociation qui doit se passer avec
chaque fournisseur soit avec le tour
opérateur soit avec l'hôtelier certains
hôteliers ne sont pas du tout enclin à
ouah faire des remboursements ou il
préfère envisager d avoir pour être sûr
que les clients vont revenir chez eux
néanmoins nous en france on est régulée
par l'ordonnancé donc on doit pouvoir
proposer aux clients en avoir qui va
durer 18 mois est au bout des 18 mois le
client pour être remboursé merci
beaucoup caroline seigneur d'avoir été
avec nous et de nous avoir tenté d'y
voir plus clair sur ce qui nous attend
cet été ça l'air d'un con flux encore en
tout cas merci à vous elle nouveau cycle
de négociations entre londres et
bruxelles sur leur relation passe break
6-5 semaines d'intenses discussions ont
débuté hier avec michel barnier le
négociateur de l'union européenne et son
homologue britannique
le but éviter un new deal à la fin de
l'année de son côté boris johnson
souhaite être fixé dès juillet sur la
possibilité d'un compromis
en attendant le royaume uni continuent
d'appliquer les règles européennes
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 et parmi les
enjeux des négociations pour trouver un
terrain d'entente pour des accords
commerciaux est la tâche est ardue les
pêcheurs notamment sont inquiets car
faute d'accords levant excite serait un
coup de massue pour leur profession
quand un mot clair ces pêcheurs français
sont en peine prises de poissons et de
crustacés
cette pêche laurent merlin la réalise
chaque jour dans les eaux territoriales
britanniques mais avec le break site
tout pourrait être remise en cause allez
on a très peur de le braille que le
président soit très dur pour ils sont
peu plus venir dans les eaux anglaises
on passe la plupart du corps dans les
eaux anglaises du coup ça serait la fin
de notre métier ce lundi le royaume uni
et l'union européenne ont repris leurs
discussions sur les relations post
breakes site avec en tête les accords
commerciaux pour le moment le royaume
uni s'oppose fermement à la volonté de
l'union européenne d'avoir un accès
durable aux eaux britanniques la fin de
l'accès des pêcheurs de l'ue aux eaux
territoriales britanniques n'auraient
pas d effet que sur les pêcheurs les
marchés aux poissons comme celui de
boulogne sur mer serait aussi grandement
les et ce qui est certain c'est que
l'impact potentiel pour nos activités de
mareyage
sur sur boulogne qui est le premier port
de pêche de france on l'estiment aux
alentours de 1/3 de l'activité donc ce
qui est quand même est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
d'après sky news la majorité des
poissons pêchées dans les eaux
britanniques sont pris par des pêcheurs
étrangers les britanniques vente
également une partie de leur prise en
dehors de leur territoire un accord
commercial semble donc indispensable
pour garantir la survie de la pêche
we need to find nous avons besoin de
trouver un accord sinon les difficultés
sociales et économiques auxquels nous
serons confrontés se traduiront
évidemment par des tensions et peut-être
aussi par des affrontements en mer
important entre les pêcheurs britannique
et ceux d'autres pays européens
ce serait une catastrophe which would be
est catastrophique l'union européenne
fait maintenant aussi face à l'urgence
dans sa volonté de sauver la pêche dans
les eaux britanniques lui et le royaume
uni espère trouver un accord d'ici à la
fin de l'année et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve à 22h pin pour un point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
une trappe est vraiment passé à côté du
problème